so hello everyone
yeah congratulations on Friday evening
super-nice my name is Vladimir okay my
name is Vladimir I'm data scientist an
engineer at signify here's my quick muon
he was lead development engineer and
this tutorial is about management of
machine learning lifecycle with the tool
called
mo flow so first of all before I start
introduction go to this github in the
readme file there's instructions what
you should do what you should install go
through it it's straightforward but if
you have questions just raise your hand
you want to help or yeah or I will help
as well
everyone check this link yep perfect so
I can go few words about signify we are
worked a leader in connection all
connected conventional LED lighting
we provide light sources luminaires
system and services on top of that and
yeah we employee I know I think now it's
more than 30,000 people around the world
and the core in our businesses and in
general in the work we do it's a
sustainability so we also number one in
though Jones Sustainability Index our
other value proposition is hajeck
horticulture connected lighting platform
for industry and businesses code
interact and recently there was a big
release about our 3d printing ventures
so if you want to 3d print design your
own luminaire check my creations it's
just Google that you will find it so
signifies a big company and within R&D
department in the digital workflow
sector we are where we are working with
Milan we mostly busy with these topics
so factory automation anomaly detection
active maintenance quality control
automated design so we're building
systems to detect anomalies in the
sensor networks to make sure that our
products quite with a quite good quality
I would say deploying deep learning
models in production and also models
that work with multivariate multivariate
time series data agenda so first I will
explain some concepts about machine
learning life cycle in general then we
have look on the tracking and model
registry components of Hemel flow and
afterwards neon will explain how you can
work with projects and models it's other
two components of mo flow you're free to
ask questions any time so just gonna
raise your hand if something is not
clear I think to be really nice so first
concepts on machine learning life cycle
I think everyone familiar with this
vicious cycle of the data so how it goes
from the raw data let's say you have I
know database or the streaming service
like Kafka or you connected to the cloud
platforms you get your raw data then
afterwards you need to do something with
this and transform it to the something
consumable by your model so using a
spark or pandas dataframes
maybe scikit-learn pipelines for that or
just simple SQL queries fixing the
missing values make sure that everything
is correct and then there's a training
phase so again if it's a traditional
machine learning thing using psychic
learn maybe for the big data or for for
the large data use cases here using
spark and if it's a deep learning as we
all know it's tons of flow and pi torch
so amazing we have the data we have our
models and then afterwards we need to do
something to bring the value for
business or in general so we need to
deploy it and for deployment there's
also a lot of options I just put some of
them you can deploy it on the cloud
there's amazing sage maker from Amazon
and
so age of machine learning labs for that
if you have local facilities for example
I know maybe spark cluster or something
you can deploy your model as a job in a
spark cluster or just wrap up in the
talker for the local testing so that's
how it looks in general and then what
we're doing daily looks quite nice but
where's the issues then so first it's
really difficult to track experiments
when you're working on your local
environment you just start experimenting
training your machine learning models
creating a models and then you can ended
up with bunch of files and titles
notebook one two until forever or I know
weights of the models that you can all I
know new model latest model final model
new final model I saw a lot of options
and that's quite difficult because in
the end you may have a really nice model
but you don't know from what parameters
on from what data even it was produced
so there's no value in this model in the
end so that's one another thing it's a
difficulty to reproduce these models so
we all using super nice latest version
of libraries we're running our jupiter
notebooks and then yeah it works fine
and let's assume your code documented
really well and you just translate it to
someone and the person is trying to run
it and then the version of libraries
changed so you use probably wait I know
now the rate of developments is quite
fast so you may use Karis 1.8 I don't
know and then next day is 2.0 and in the
room in the best case you will run this
code and you will get some random
performance of the model in the best
case in the worst case you will be not
able to run this code at all so
packaging the whole code and environment
though
parameters it's also really important
for the machine learning projects
another thing it's deployment and the
thing is there's no standard way to
deploy your model and what I noticed
also working with different teams is
that for a particular tool there's a
particular way of to deploy for a
particular version of the of the tool it
could be a particular way to deploy and
usually what what's the most troublesome
place its link between the model that
you deploy and experiment so you may
have production engineer or someone in
your company that actually expecting
from you to model he will deploy it and
then this track between this model and
your experiments is also gone so this is
some kind of high-level overview of the
issues that may occur there's much more
out of it and my flow is trying to solve
this so mo flow is really I would say
early vibrates like one year and a half
maybe out there and there's a several
components that trying to help you to
solve these issues first one it's the
tracking component it allows you to
record all your experiments for example
you did a lot of experiments today for
the other workshops right training
neural networks you was trying to find
the proper parameters you just many
manually maybe changing it and then not
storing it anywhere so tracking
component will help for that another one
is the model registry this is something
for the data science teams when you're
working with the group of people and
then you probably working on the same
project and you would like to be aware
of the progress of your colleagues so I
mean maybe they already deployed or
developed a better model than you and
it's nice to know that and more model
registry allows you to share review and
manage these models within the team what
else I move flow projects it's the
packaging format anyone will go more in
details about that but basically what it
allows you to do it allows you to wrap
up any machine learning model or almost
any machine learning model
for the easiest reproducible runs on any
other platforms whether it's cloud
platform or local deployment and the
last one it's models so this is the
format for the model itself what's the
difference between two project could be
could contain multi-step there are
several steps so it could be multi-step
workflow incorporated in one project and
then model it's particularly for one
model you incorporate all the
dependencies that you need you kind of
pickle your model file on weights and
it's also available so that's more or
less as an overview for ML phone we will
move to the first tutorial part so we
discussed the tracking and model
registry so once again who's there just
yeah continue installing the
dependencies and run the notebooks first
I will explain some features of the of
the tracking UI so as you can see here
tracking UI allows you to see the date
of the experiment the user who did the
experiment the source code and the
version of it it's also allows you to
search through experiments visualize the
metrics compare for the guys who using
turns or board for example some
capabilities of a tensor board and we'll
also incorporates but I just want to
highlight maybe I think it's relevant to
highlight the difference turns our board
it's inside of the terms of flow waker
system so it's quite easy quite
difficult to isolate terms important
uses for cyclic learn pipelines for
example mo phone in that sense it's
standalone tool
- it's just Python API you can use it
for any experiments not necessarily
related to machine learning even if you
want to track something
what are you doing some optimization I
don't know it it works to try so yeah
let's go to the tracking Python API
notebook inside of the
repository who managed to install the
dependencies Oh perfect that's strange
and everything is working okay okay let
me see
we try to use Jupiter lap previously
okay some people so yeah
Jupiter lap it's kind of I would say
better version of Jupiter notebook that
will put all Jupiter notebooks and also
nice Explorer of the files and stuff in
one for in one tab so you don't have to
create ten tabs with different Jupiter
notebooks so yeah just to explain a bit
before we start so this particular
command here the mo flow server in the
project directory you will find the
folder called back-end and inside
there's already a SQLite database this
database will be used for model registry
to keep your all experiments there and
the metadata another folder there is
called artifact store in this folder for
heavy artifacts so your model weights
images plots whatsoever all goes to the
artifact store there's another command
that if this one will not work called mo
fo UI it will just create mm runs folder
inside of your directory and then yeah
this one is for those who want to see
how right model registry is working and
it's preferable to run on Windows you
have to kind of add several slashes and
yeah you know this it was solve is like
this so let's go then okay the first
notebook is quite straightforward so
just yeah so as I mentioned tracking API
works in the concept of runs so first
you define your experiment and then each
run kind of compress your data science
code and all the walks and matrix and
params
in
go and put it in the UI that you can
easily look at that
so yeah it's also supports four other
languages like our Java and I mean in
general it's the rest API that you can
use with everything so first if you run
successfully Emma flow by the way for
those who using Jupiter lab you can also
run it directly from the from the
terminal inside of the Jupiter lap if
you for some reason what's going on by
the way okay interesting
okay so the first first thing that you
need to do you need to specify your
tracking your eye since you're running
it on are on the laptops it's just
localhost with the port 5000 just copy
it here and then okay
so if you want to use them all fall
within the team you can use a remote
server and store or store all
experiments there and then the URI will
be just different and then you can
specify and the name and our court would
say here for me to type test so
apparently already have it one and this
is basically the whole story about the
UI so you need to start the run inside
of the run you can do whatever you want
lock the parameters lock the things that
changes through the experiment for
example for machine learning experiments
you want lock accuracy or training loss
or validation loss so let's just put
something here like something simple and
it's kind of a dream accuracy curve for
machine learning if you just run it you
get 100% accuracy in there so let's
let's make one run ok it's done and then
now I need to switch to the mo flow UI
so here I have on the left there is a
list of experiments that I just tried
and the one that we did it's called test
and here there is a one run think it's
now so yeah I have the parameters here
this alpha and beta and if you are going
side there's a whole information about
the experiment that I did if you're
using not Jupiter lab for for the
experiments but a normal script you will
have a source path and also if you're
using Emma for projects you will get the
full source path to your project and
then you see there's like several groups
of values attack here parameters matrix
paths you can use tax to label something
when it's
production rage or not and then for
example you can visualize accuracy so
this is the best accuracy and that would
be a lot of parameters you can put tens
of them and we realize all of it here in
a nice interface so this is nice what
else we can do
I created a funny function that will
draw in a heart so there are some
parameters for that so in soldiers I
need to specify the name of the another
experiment I will call it heart it's a
new one and then there are some
parameters so you can change the color
of the background the color of the text
the text itself what I want to emphasize
here that you can store also locks and
and graphs in mo flow so what I'm doing
I'm just keeping all the information in
one folder it's a temporary folder for
experiment then with this command lock
artifacts the whole folder goes to demo
flow UI server it's stored there and
then I'm just deleting the temporary
folder and that's it so let's run it
machine it's my heart you can define any
other one reminds me about this new one
I would say yeah so yeah let's see
whether it's tracked in the in the
server because it could be it was cold
yeah I'm smoked so basically yeah
there's also some tag now here and and
now artifact is not empty so there's a
lock with some message hello pie data
and and the image there as well now this
is some time example that give you an
idea how the UI working and what you can
track there so let's move them to
another notebook that a bit more serious
than this one the second one
so here I decided to just use a simple
machine learning task image
classification we did that a lot today
in various forms and yeah no one is
using now simple minced data set with
handwritten digits because it's too
simple so I decided to use this yah-hoo
sushi gym in East numbers data set it's
quite difficult to pronounce but
basically story behind it is that it's
it's all the Japanese script that was
used for 1,000 years and then at some
point in time they stopped teaching it
at school and then people forgot how to
use it so it somehow reminds me the
story with the legacy code inside of the
organization when someone is writing it
and then you have a new developer and
then no one knows how to use the stuff
so that's why I pick that for for for
the example so it looks like this
basically so it's a typical minis but
just a bit more difficult because it's a
Japanese script and not numbers so yeah
here we have some parameters that we may
want to change things like a batch size
test batch size amount of epochs the
seed learning rate we already touched
some of these parameters today during
the previous workshop so I'm not going
to explain it but you feel free to ask
and since I'm using PI torch and I'm
using it locally I created a super
simple neural network architecture that
called also net with only two blocks of
convolutional layers which should run on
your CPU if it's at least I five CPU I
hope quite fast yeah I'm also not going
to describe the architecture it's just
simple neural network with few
convolutional layers and fully connected
layer in the end so and we have ten
classes the same task as a traditional M
nice data set they just a bit different
so this for these two cells first one is
preparing the data set and if you don't
have it it will start
automatically it's kind of data set
features that goes with by torch
altogether there are some transforms
that applies to data set that can post
in the in the first line
so we transform each image to the PI
torch tensor and then applying some
normalization so it's really important
to to do before fitting it to neural
network and then there's a data loader
data loader directly put the images to
the neural network from your data set
and important parameters here its page
size and shuffling an amount of workers
so if you're working in in in the
environment with a lot of compute power
you may change numbers to amount of
course that you have in your machine and
then it will go super fast then model
and optimizer this code is kind of
agnostic to device so if in your laptop
you have a GPU and CUDA installed to
automatically detect and put your code
to the GPU so yeah and also optimizer
I'm using stochastic gradient descent
for simplicity and there's two
parameters learning rate and momentum
for that next to that there are training
and testing functions which is quite
common and for the image classification
task we iterating through data set here
and then putting the data to device so
as I said whether CPU or GPU calculating
the gradients and our outputs of the
model and then we we doing first forward
propagation and back propagation
standard steps for image classification
and at some point it's calculates the
the train was for the training for the
test the idea is the same with the only
difference that there's this small
context manager torch no grad which is
not updating your model do
the tests and all other stuff is more or
less the same we're calculating the test
loss and test accuracy so what basically
changed with this code what we should
add to track it to the in ml flow so as
you can see here I add walk metric wine
so just one line of code and two lines
of code here so this will allow us
already to put a lot of information
about this experiment to the web UI an
experiment itself it's the same you
still need to specify the tracking your
I create an experiment put the manual
seat I think for CPU this manual seat
will work for the GPU you need put more
efforts for the photo torch particularly
to make sure that your code is
reproducible and then here I'm not going
to run it but basically yeah because I
already did we just training the neural
network monitoring the laws and accuracy
on the test set and in the end I think I
put 10 a box of something you probably
have three or one in if from the github
so yeah that's nice so basically we have
86 percent accuracy with the simple
model for the recognition of this
Japanese script perfect what next we can
do with this thing let's go to ammo flow
where's that here and we'll check our
experiment so what I can see here and
you as well we have a bunch of
experiments that was done on this data
set before they're always the different
test accuracy with different parameters
and and with different metrics as well
so in UI for example you can sort
experiments according to your accuracy
and see particularly that my last run is
the most successful run out of all of
them
it's like 86 the previous one was yeah
80 and you can also see the test laws
and the train was and if you go to the
experiments here there's a yeah you can
also compare them it maybe not fit
properly to the to the screen if there
is a much of experiments but in the end
you can see some kind of graph that
based on some parameters like yeah we
can probably pick the amount of epochs
this is could be something that showing
that the more epochs we are training our
model the better the accuracy is the
same time you can compare it with other
different things some questions so far
sorry this one ah you mean here yeah I
think it was the same one epic so they
that's why they are together they was
run with the same on the x-axis its
number of epochs so I assume for these
two runs it was the same and the
difference in accuracy probably not that
significant so it's 74 and seventy three
point seven that's why they nearby yes
it's from the same experiments but it's
from the same experiment but from
different runs so this is the last one
and you can also see the parameters and
things like this okay so that's nice so
we have a nice UI we have kind of
comparison between our experiments out
of the box but then how we will connect
it to our deployment environment so here
the model registry comes into play and
for this I will just go for the for the
latest example so here we see she in the
artifacts there's a model file that
contains basically current environment
with all dependencies that was used
among modo mio model file it's exactly
the the format that I was talking about
which incorporates all information about
your model so how it was utilized within
the demo flow
what kind of Python version is there
stuff like that and there's some data
here and the data it's exactly the
weights of the model so and you can
download it it's easier vailable for
everyone but what else you can do you
can also register the model so if you
did everything correctly with the
database and stuff you will see this
button and then let's click on it I
already Heaven would say a model called
Kimmy's classifier with the previous
results so let's do the same so
registering the same kind of for the
same model the newest version and this
is something that called model registry
so here you see the source run from
which model was produced by the way you
can also add description here for the I
mean it could be the link somewhere with
the explanation or something else you
see also to date when the run was
created so it's just now and you also
can specify the stage here so whether
it's if you still experimenting this
model can goes to the staging if
something that obsolete and not used it
will be archived or if you want to put
it in production yeah you can put it in
production who's for those who is using
data bricks platform within the
companies they allowed managed demo flow
servers so you can basically specify
what users can put models from staging
to production and so on if you using it
as a standalone locally you will not
have that functionality available
so let's first check our in general
what's going on with our model so this
is a story several versions we have five
versions
two of them are archived one in
production and this one is staging and
the last one there's nothing but we know
that from the comparison of experiments
that the latest model was quite better
than previous one so what you can do you
can archive this model which was the
version 3 and put version 5 directly to
production why not it's not running
anything underneath but you can imagine
since it's open API you can easily
integrate it with your CI CD tools just
go edit it which model you should take
and it's available you can download it
through the API the latest model and put
it into production the way you want or
the way as mo flow allows to do that so
let's back to the presentation
yeah now it's just changing the Hilton
the database so the model is it's it's
just a indication how your models are
exist in the database that's it yes yeah
yes you can you can you can do that
that's the that's the advantage of of mo
flow it's open API you can easily adapt
it for your needs so I have some
examples when mo flow integrated with
things like I don't know Jenkins for
example and stuff like that so it's it's
it's up to you because I know that in
different organizations people use ICD
different is for ci City so that's why
they not picked one particular one okay
so we stopped here yeah yeah it's a good
question I can just give you a hint but
no one is going to discuss more about
that so there's a several so called
flavors of the models that mo flow can
use by default like PRS tensorflow
onyx models scikit-learn models and
there's another one called python
function which allows you to wrap up any
Python code as the model so yeah but
they will be more about that later so
yeah just to wrap up model registry so
you have repository of version models
with description you can change the
stage of it yeah
well that's the tricky question it's not
stupid because you need to have an
agreement within the team if you're
using open source versions so you have
probably the idea of what projects you
are doing the naming conventions of the
of the of the projects should be fixed
otherwise everyone start creating their
own experiments with the same name and
you have a mess but if you if you
organize it properly it's it will it
used very well and overview of the
models that in production as I mentioned
previously if you put it in the into the
sunshine CD - where's that so basically
yeah this is the UI it's not showing
okay just play the presentation mode for
a second
yeah so I think if you add slash models
in your MMO flow instance after the port
you will see something like this there's
only one model but you have everything
the latest version some some stages of
other previous versions the datas was
created and you can also check would say
that particular version go for the run
and this is the run this is the code and
this is the model so that's that's the
overview kind of I have my doubts about
you I I would say but that's a nice
attempt I would say
yes it depends
yeah if it's hot for the data science
teams usually you're working on the one
project within small team of people like
two or three probably then it's
manageable because you can have
agreement if it's a big I don't know
group of people like big data science
team like 50 people or more then you
need to have a proper proper management
of this may be managed air mo flow good
work from that so yeah let me wrap up
yeah that's easy toward a specific
version of your model from the UI
directly
so to summarize the tracking server its
isolated component you can use it even
not attaching to the model registry or
to previous things that I mentioned it
allows you to track parameters metrics
artifacts metadata about your experiment
and models model registry it's something
that allows you to see an overview of
what your data science team is doing
actually what the version of the latest
models whether they're in production or
archived and it's also something that
you can provide for development
engineers who's going to deploy these
models into production yeah I think
that's yeah I think I have some use
cases that I just briefly mentioned so
if you are kind of a single data
scientist in the in the company or in
the project you can use it locally you
don't have to think about deployments
just run it locally and use it per
project basis yeah you can if it's a
team I would suggest to deploy an
offload server remotely somewhere in the
cloud or if you have a server and give
access to the team and to all members
and you need to set up conventions for
the naming and other things to use it
efficiently and not create a mess inside
of the organization you can also put a
single sign-on before the mo flow server
and define the roles it's all possible
it's not yet available in the
open-source version but it will be
because actually the the registry
component was released one month ago so
it's quite new feature anyway just to
give her a note to the other tools that
available today there was a workshop
about airflow I just would like to
highlight the difference so airflow it's
workflow management system you can
schedule whatever you want there like
ETL pipelines machine learning pipelines
and so on in the Morpho you can also
schedule multi-step workflows but it's
not really recommended it's possible to
do but
for the heavy things it's better to use
airflow and there's another tool there's
one component that I didn't mention that
memo flow is not tracking is your data
so for example if someone changed your
data in s3 bucket or you know in some
repository and you train your model on
top of that it's quite difficult okay
you can have some process saved
parameters and save metadata but if data
is changed itself for example images you
was classifying a Japanese script but
someone put pictures of dogs and cats
instead and then you like wondering
what's going on there's another tool
called GDC I think it's short for data
version control it's based on the get
heavily and it allows you to version
your data so every time you add in new
data or changing your data set it allows
you to do that it works heavily with the
git that's more or less it from my side
and me on please
[Music]
okay so thanks for the me the next two
parts are quite quick we keep you too
long from beers and food models quickly
and also about projects so projects
projects invention really or directory
that contains a clutch the files and
those files define your data science
project so like I said it's a convention
based format for packaging data science
in a reusable reusable way ml flow gives
you an API and a bunch of command-line
tools to help you work with projects and
also to chain together projects in work
closest vladimir said what is the
structure of a project well I said it
was a character or git repo the minimum
is you need Conda llamo file and that is
used as your default environment if you
don't provide a condor llamo file it
uses a standard Python environment
optionally you can supply an ml project
file and that includes the extra
configuration everyone knows what I want
to convey yellow file is hopefully
contains all your dependencies the mo
project file have contains your project
name entry points for your project the
environment that you're going to be
using whether it's from the Condor
whether it's going to be darker whether
it's going to be the system environment
and any additional work flow stages
defined so on screen I've got a sample
file at the top you can see the name and
environment specified here I've got
Conda you can specify a docker
environment as well with that you would
use a different tag and here after that
you have entry points and you have
several different entry points here so
one for doing etl one for training and
you have a main entry point as well at
the bottom with each of these entry
points you can specify parameters
specify the parameter type and also
specify default values for those
parameters so if you want to bake him
something into that configuration you
can just run that without complicating
your runtime so I've said already that
the project environment can have three
different types of environments so
Condor docker and system environments so
docker realms will be useful if you're
using JVM projects in Scala or Java
executables or if you have net
dependencies system environment if
you're doing something else or you can't
package up everything you need to inside
a docker we have a docker example here
when you create a docker project from ml
flow the docker image will talk to the
tracking API from Aero flow and also
mount the email runs folder into the
docker VM and it's possible to use a
local or remote docker registry for your
images I mentioned you could also
specify parameters so for each parameter
you have to specify the name the type
whether it's a floats training path URI
and a default value so if you want to
bake in some environment file
environment or URL type of things into
your project you can do that very easily
so running a project I said the
beginning project there is a way to
reproduce your machine learning
environment so what that allows you to
do is you have an entry point the
introvert can be run using NL flow by
the command line so at the bottom I
specified
and the local file I've said ml slow run
the Python file and I've supplied a
parameter you can also just run directly
from a git repo so if you've checked
something in and you can just say and
also I'll run and it'll run your example
based on git
and you can also run your project on a
spark cluster if that's available as
discussed earlier maybe it's not the
best solution for this kind of stuff but
it does support multi-step workflows
within a project and with additional
projects so it's it's it's a handy thing
to have if you don't want to roll your
own batch file or if you want to go all
the way to airflow there's in between
area where you can automate some tooling
so this is just an example of a
multi-step to go to demo just bear with
me for a second my switch
so here I've got no no Japanese script
unfortunately I think it's but a 1:1
quality example so I'm just going to run
through this just to show you how to run
ml flow models oh no wrong way around
we'll do the projects
alright so as mentioned before this is
in the github repo I just reiterate some
of the things that you kind of need to
set things up I'm just gonna scroll all
the way down
so here I ran a mlo project using the
system environment I specified no
contact and basically that used all the
dependencies that I've already installed
and ran that project and then that
succeeded happily the main file printed
out two lines of text PyCon ml projects
and the parameters I supplied from the
project file I'll just take a quick look
to Shh
my code so you should have this already
the condor llamo park specializes
dependencies the mo flow project
specifies a condor environment yeah I've
got a docker example as well so if you
want to create a docker environment or
run run this project inside the docker
container then you can specify it in the
door and it'll generate the dock of
container for you and then run it in
that and here I specified the entry
point so parameter 1 2 and 3 of type
integer and then main command to start
this application and the main PI
function is just basically a print
screen I take the parameters from from
the application plug them in I have some
defaults if they're if they're not
supplied and then I just put them out
correctly yeah so it's pretty
straightforward with a template to roll
your own project environment to do all
kinds of things
so that's an MMO full project we
packaged a directory we use a machine
learning model and then we can package
as dr. environment and then just run
with a pre-cut environment now if we
look at mo floor models what I am are
four models and although models are
sorry let me just kill that
okay
so the yellow flow model format allows
you to basically use a number of machine
learning packages and provide a common
format to be able to use those
environments and also acts as a model
converter so you can plug something in
run it with a specific environment and
then save out different model formats
that can be used in different libraries
and the model component also allows you
to deploy to a rest endpoint Apache
spark it'll be a stage maker and as your
Annelle model flavors there are lots of
models later supported so our cameras
any cyclic flow and you also got a
Python function custom flavor then you
can roll your own functionality and have
that set up basically you've got a
number of commands that allow you to
build a docker file and do predictions
do serving also deploy to is your horse
age maker
so once you've run your model you can
serve that model out using commands oh
and all models serve and then you
specify the run ID which you saw
previously and the model path and then
what we're gonna do is we're gonna call
that model and do some inference on that
we just have a quick demo
so in the third notebook we learn about
dependencies
we'd also take a look at the directory
structure that is kind of interesting
because there's a whole bunch of files
that you need to know and get familiar
with so wherever you started your ml
flow application if you specified a
specific starting location using command
line as Vladimir showed then you don't
know your ever runs will end up in one
directory location if you don't have any
of that which is what I was doing
earlier today you will have wherever you
started your ml flow application and ml
runs directory inside there and then for
each run you will have a set of
artifacts in the model and in that model
directory you have a pickle file a model
specification and some dependencies to
run that model as well so in anaconda
yellow file pretty straightforward it's
similar to what you seen before in the
ml model file you can specify what
flavors of model that you want to deploy
to so here we have a vital function or
the pickle file will be and what the
environment for that will be and also we
have an SK learn variant of that and for
this particular deployment where we're
saying wouldn't be using this run ID
so if I go ahead and run this so I've
connected to my mo flows over that's
running on my system I'll load up the
one quality data
I've got so here that's loaded next step
is to define our calculation function
for our quality metrics put that in and
just in training there we go and the
next thing is to see what run IDs we've
got so typically it'll be the last one
you've done so you can pick that and
this is the date this is just some
sample data what I've picked from the
input file just to plug into the
entrance for the server that's running
okay
if I do a call to my local host I've
started the server on put one two three
four
offering vacations then I supply the
input data for that so the fixed acidity
citric acid sugar chlorides all the
metrics I need or the input variables I
need four to make the inference whether
or not this is a quality why not and
these are the column values and then we
have the actual data values here so if I
go ahead and how with that out it
doesn't work do you think I started this
one here
there we go
so I've deployed model the specific run
ID to a rest endpoint and I can send
coal request to it and get at the bottom
okay it's also possible to I deploy
these bottles to Sage maker and to Azure
and also the kubernetes so so there's
lots of possibilities to deploy bottles
in a very easy way yeah so I think
that's it any questions
I think I said them No so basically as
you just seen you can use mo flow for
your local deployments for the cloud
deployments I suggest you to start using
it if you like this tutorial start our
github repository if you don't like it
create issue there and explain why you
don't like it negative feedback is also
useful we are here we still have some
time for your questions or we can
continue with discussion so feel free
yeah if there's no questions then yeah
that's it
[Applause]